[Music]
we are all here for the same thing for
freedom for democracy for
justice and to continue to denounce the
police violence which continues to
grow on the other side and we will
not let it happen today France
will not  cannot give a moral lesson to
any other country today
its police are racist its police are
violent
[Music]
cannot even exist while being
dead we want to hide
police violence we want to hide the denial of
justice we want to hide the  silence of
the French state in the face of our dead
[Music] [
Music]
last word it's not them who have it, it's
us who have the last word
because we are marching for justice
today our freedom is  flouted
today, France cannot say
that it is in a democratic state,
which is false, we have been forbidden to
march